[Music]
there was a time when seabees would
ravage our shores
and no ship was safe on the sea
but those days are over
today valiant warriors battle the beasts
far beyond the horizon
you're jacob holland a weapon against
nature's darkest design and i'm joining
your crew oh no you ain't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you stowed away i
yeah
i like this kid
we're dropping you off at the nearest
port hunting ship ain't no place for a
kid but you joined the ship when you
were the age
look at you now
that's not the same thing isn't it
no
it isn't
the drake more thick with monsters
monsters don't want to eat us we're not
keeping it but he's so cute
you and i have a different idea of cute
just
don't move
this be going
i see a fire in her
same fire i saw in you
the monsters i can handle
we got it right where we want it
that one
she'll be the death of me
i swore i would do everything in my
power to keep people safe you can be a
hero and still be wrong
the ocean has sent us it's worse
then we'll send it right back
i've always wanted a pet that's not a
pet but i already named it let me guess
blue
uh
[Music]